my god I'd cry good name right
you're so handsome thank you your I
answer can you change your it if you're
the guy you thought I was gonna be we
got the beer belly
I'm the Friday night Amy today it was
excitement I understand their bodily
inventory fists this is a necessary oh I
like this wallpaper I love what you've
done with the place crying I don't know
how I did it
can you show me around sure well those
are doors uh-huh and yep this place all
right
we can run by the way okay and here's my
gun collection whoa I don't have guns
actually just this one how do you climb
on I can only punch them II that should
have been oh oh Japanese whoa yes what
do I want like we can also pick up
chairs oh my god Rafi I call him bluey
back in the day that was good hell
that's beautiful all right what would
your old machete maybe whoa all right
this is Ruben out at I don't really know
much of this game crying you're the
expert I guess oh my Chris Thomas I just
stole your machete is that a watermelon
no it's not all right Phil a watermelon
actually oh no no it's a ball if it but
yeah it's it's like a protection ball
it's shaking I'm sure it's very Ameri
uncomfortable to be a slice by jax-ur
okay that's probably why all right so
let's get signing okay we really need
some butter
it's sharp those I'm gonna take a
flashlight because it's gonna be dark as
hell
hi Japan oh okay and we'll need sitting
places though we need a chairs okay of
course
okay good we are ready for anything
we're going to rock what I should also
mention I have no idea where to go in
this map okay I've never been here so
how about we hang out in here we have
TVs oh good
and this is a clip well I'm leaving do
it I'm sorry I just heard it on the
flashlight and how do I turn it down Oh
Oh shucks come here shotgun yes Mike and
I G and then no don't drop your friend
oh you got a you got to drop your other
thing I can't yes oh good
yes what are you doing that [ __ ] what is
going on I'm the cook good you share
listen to me it doesn't like us very
much
ah you might want to go shotgun shells
by the way okay
seasons right here and the Reming I'm
sorry after you share our Don you all
right okay all right I'm taking your
chair now nah
dang it all right taking your shirt I
really like oh I thought where to go by
the way okay yeah I knew it
that was very wet what you said you
didn't know okay whoa come on noise whoa
ladies look at it touch it appropriate
interpret just like going right outside
her travel bed it was a great night
games really awkward Oh Mike I know
all right my god are we doing this
Carla go to the second floor final
answer
we're landing are there I can't go try
there come on a fire shut up bitter why
are we here we go oh wait the game
sounds really loud I hate you know you
can pop got that girl oh good okay I
think it's better not okay
all right good we gather the wind is so
loud when does it dick but I don't think
we need what is he doing
whoa I take a life right thank you
oh yes what are we doing we should go
them yeah um there
here we go can we take oh this is where
we have to take a ladder partying we
gotta go find a ladder and then put it
there oh we need to go okay back to the
[ __ ] sand with weight right little
different way it felt super loud what
the [ __ ]
use your volume mixer oh yeah
but if I tap out I would like see one of
this restart entirely now again it's a
good job round get it going here all
right well it's dark all right try it's
very light outside
ah thank God it's not coming here yes
okay it's really dark it is
we need our flashlights well they know
our door Bhandari what user puzzle comes
back on it lasted I good whoa
there's stairs over here alright cool
stop opening the door to have it all
right where do we go where do we go here
we have baron I was super was that it
looks like we got to explode this okay
my car I lose that made Ninja Turtles
back I I've been laughing oh wow which
right oh hello ah first case all right
Java okay I don't feel safe anymore and
you really suppose that Enrique I found
a secret exit
oh that was secret as hell I can't great
okay all right that's because you're a
large American man oh wow look at this
oh I am fat I don't see myself oh okay
um oh that's a red thing there does that
mean you should blow it up what where oh
maybe
okay we're like running down there stop
running did not copy challenge you know
what let's go nah you're always Babu no
didn't students I'd run all right I
might be crap but get up here quick okay
how do you Google America my child good
she wanted you another baby
yes I can't shoot it another people
never change to Jesus
huh did it freaking zombie babies
alright cry named Michael my time to
shine your shadow is a beautiful
majestic thing to baby oh god oh god
whoo serious no you can't be done I'm
sorry man I don't even have a flashlight
toilets here a girl just go to bathroom
now I know they're coming in the house
oh no oh I was doing this okay
you know that a fight this is a toilet I
just rose from the dead
you know no I'll cry did you become one
of them I have become one of them I am
so sad all right
oh maybe the other peeps there's a bed
out there they're just hanging out Ivan
why did I go in here cry
I don't know friend you might not do huh
Oh God well the buddy who lives
oh you buy it down that's my but you die
really quick once they get chat yeah you
do and I rice on top of a crash and you
look very majestic up there I think we
should give this another try what do you
think I think we should all right anion
you sever me yeah because yeah
I'll do that
- lucky oh yeah